remember grifball the multiplayer mode  full of balls and hammers and swords  it's coming to halo 5 this month  developer 343 Industries has worked to  ensure that grifball plays just the way  it should flying out community member  Jeffrey no cured Fischer to help design  the game mode multiplayer designer max  Grossman said that bringing him out was  important to understanding what makes  Grifball so appealing he continues we  had many design discussions with no  cured and he even built the first halo 5  Grifball court which will be launching  alongside the mode this update it's  unlike any Grifball court you've ever  seen before playing gryffald during play  tests over the last few months has been  some of the most fun we've had in the  new building grifball isn't the only new  mode coming to halo 5 either neutral  bomb assault in fiesta are also coming  back you can read all about the update  on Halo Waypoint and for all the halo 5  news you need keep reading gamespot  you